escenas
estos niños están a punto de jugar al
monopolio pero no el tradicional aquí
los jugadores no empiezan la partida en
igualdad de condiciones
a cada niño se le asigna un papel al
azar y algunos son más privilegiados que
otros el monopolio ha sido adaptado por
el observatorio de las desigualdades
para ser utilizado con fines educativos
[Música]
el objetivo es realmente informarle
sobre el estado de las desigualdades en
francia sin encerrarlos en una
observación fatalista en la que salgan
de una sesión diciendo que en cualquier
caso las desigualdades son tales que no
tiene sentido intentarlo y que su futuro
ya está trazado de antemano de rajarse
pagamos
[Música]
estos escolares de la capital francesa
descubren que algunos son más iguales
que otros
es para mostrar las desigualdades pero
el hecho de enfrentarse a eso
directamente pues no me gustó porque
pensé que en la vida real hay gente que
realmente vive eso pero más duro
las reglas del juego fueron diseñadas
para reflejar la realidad
y
los trenes actuales sería mejor asignar
rampas por ejemplo en el tr en el r r
para las personas en silla de ruedas
la herramienta del juego funciona muy
bien para que discutan un tema que es
complicado un tema social que puede ser
difícil excepto que no tenemos
suficiente tiempo cada vez para entrar
en todo por eso es muy importante para
nosotros trabajar en colaboración con
los profesores o educadores para que
puedan continuar el trabajo que
iniciamos con esta sesión a excepción
preguntas difíciles abordadas con un
enfoque original el observatorio de las
desigualdades espera promover reglas más
justas para todo el mundo